dans ce journal la mort de loulou gasté
compositeur de chansons populaires la
sécurité en question en corse
les affrontements en tchétchénie du
cinéma et la sortie mercredi d'un
nouveau frankenstein sous les traits de
robert de niro et puis nous fêterons les
50 ans du journal le monde une nouvelle
formule que nous dit qu découvriront en
compagnie de jean marie colombani son
directeur en direct de la rédaction du
monde avec le coup de crayon également
dévastateur du célèbre plantu il nous
accompagne tout au long de ce jour n'est
pour commencer notre édition hommage au
compositeur loulou gasté décédé ce matin
à l'âge de 88 ans il était l'un des
pères de la chanson populaire ma cabane
au canada battling joe feeling ce de son
épouse line renaud loulou gasté disait
elle est ma voix et elle répondait il
est ma musique
éric perrin et luc bachofen est blottie
au fond des bois on y voit des écureuils
sur le ce
si la porte n'a pas de recul
ce qu'il n'ya rien à voler sous le toit
de ma cabane loulou accompagnant à la
guitare celle pour qu'il composa toute
sa vie c'est dans les années 30 qu'il
commence sa carrière avec l' orchestre
de ray ventura
mais très vite il devient l'un des
compositeurs français les plus prolixes
avec notamment battling joe lunapark vos
rides montant il est l'artisan d'un
nombre impressionnant de succès line
renaud la toujours associé à sa réussite
et il est très rare qu'il chante lui
même en public après simplement roi de
la chanson populaire ses compositions
trotte dans toutes les têtes
démonstration combien au ce chien dans
la bible
les violents combien mots ce chien dans
la vitrine
et bien c'est certain air font le tour
du monde
alors bien sûr on essaye de le plagier
écrite en 1956 pour les besoins d'un
film pour toi va donner lieu à une
incroyable bataille juridique
jacques reprises en anglais par maurice
albert sous le titre feeling ce cette
chanson est un tube mondial ce n'est
qu'en 87
un tribunal américain rendra justice à
louis castex sur ces musiques il ya un
mot qui revient souvent amour pour ses
75 en ligne lui fait cadeau de cette
chanson intitulée do nous
dieu je t'aime